mittlerweile färbe ich mir nicht mehr
meine Haare um was Neues auszuprobieren
sondern um einen grauen Haare abzudecken
diese area hat es ganz besonders eilig
weiß zu werden und vielleicht tue ich es
und schneide mir noch ein Pony
ich gehe nämlich morgen auf dem 35
Geburtstag und ich möchte nicht dass die
Leute aus Versehen mir gratulieren und
ich war heute im Nagelstudio ein vorher
let's go also ein bisschen viel wie
immer Leute das hier ist kein Tutorial
brauche wirklich kein balayage oder so
ein Kram ich will einfach nur dass die
Leute denken dass das meine
Naturhaarfarbe ist damit die anderen
Geburtstagsgäste morgen nicht denken
dass niemand auf dem Kopf gekackt hat
haben wir die Ränder noch ein bisschen
sauber
sieht sehr aus wie Döner ist die
Temperatur gut so graue Haare ich habe
keine grauen Haare es ist touch me
leichte ich habe eigentlich eine
Friseurin Schere aber jetzt habe ich
kennt ihr diese Schere keine Ahnung wie
die funktioniert gell
und das ist das nachher vielen Dank dass
ihr eure Zeit verschwenden durfte bis
zum nächsten Mal